Speaker 1: In other in other Kevin McCarthy
news, which is not quite as funny as him selling
T-shirts calling themselves morons, Nancy
Pelosi has actually called Kevin McCarthy
out for something serious when to read from
this insider article.
Pelosi office rips into Republicans for terrorizing
Capitol Police after Trump called officer
a murderer.
Now, Donald Trump still has his little blog,
his little website where he issues statements.
How does he phrase them?
Statement by Donald J. Trump.
Forty fifth president of the United States
of America, sounds real official on his little
blog reading from The Insider.
Before we get to that, though, a spokesperson
for House Speaker Nancy Pelosi on Thursday
excoriated Republicans after former President
Donald Trump called a Capitol police officer
a murderer as he continued to whitewash the
deadly January six insurrection that he incited.
Quote, The former president's threat against
a U.S. Capitol police officer is only the
latest in a long line of vile Republican attacks
on the officers who risked their lives to
protect the United States Capitol on January
6th.
In recent weeks, Republicans have slandered
these officers as executioners and murderers
and insulted their intelligence and integrity
on national television, spokesperson Robin
Patterson said in a statement.
Enough is enough, Paterson said.
Officers present that day who have called
out the partizan efforts to downplay a violent
insurrection have been subjected to death
threats and racist abuse.
No member of the House Republican leadership
has bothered to condemn this harassment or
speak out in support of these officers, Paterson
went on to say.
Pelosi spokesperson said GOP efforts to malign
Capitol police officers are disgusting, wrong
and a wholly unacceptable way to treat the
officers who went through hell to protect
our democracy from armed insurrectionists.
The article wraps here.
Paterson said it's long overdue for Minority
Leader Kevin McCarthy to get off his hands
and stand up to the members of his Congress
and party who have been terrorizing the brave
officers that saved the lives of countless
workers, staff, journalists and members on
January six.
It's no less than these heroes deserve.
And of course, Kevin McCarthy's office did
not respond with comment.
So what what sparked this was this statement
from Donald Trump on his goofy little blog
site where he said this.
I spoke to the wonderful mother and devoted
husband of Ashley Babbitt, who was murdered
at the hands of someone who should never have
pulled the trigger of his gun.
We know who he is.
If that happened to the other side, there
would be riots all over America.
And yet there are far more people represented
by Ashley who truly loved America than there
are on the other side.
The radical left haters cannot be allowed
to get away with this.
There must be justice.
There is veiled threatening language in that
statement.
We know who he is.
Listen, Ashleigh Babbitt was tragically killed
by police while she was in in an attempted
overthrow of the United States government,
she endeavored to overturn a free and fair
election.
She attempted in the middle of a riot a violent
overthrow of the government.
She attempted to enter the House floor through
a broken window of a barred door, a blocked
door.
If she had entered, who knows what other insurrectionist
would have made it into the United States
House chamber and who knows what kind of carnage,
what kind of violence, what kind of melee
would have taken place.
Actually, Babbette was an adherent of Kuhnen.
The same conspiracy theory group that believes
Hillary Clinton ripped off the face of children
and drink their blood to imbue herself with
the power of a drain, a chrome or some other
nonsense.
Kuhnen is dangerous, the federal government
has warned that there is a threat of domestic
terror surrounding people who believe the
theory, it is not something to take lightly.
Actually, Babbitt was
not murdered.